here's how you can figure out if you
should rent or buy here it is so there's
something called
the price to rent ratio i mean i've been
a big advocate of renting because i did
the numbers in my head but i came across
this uh formula i was like holy we
got to talk about this so something
called the price to rent ratio
um
and basically what you do is you take
the median home price in your area and
you divide
by the median annual rent let me give
you a case example so you can go into
the u.s census bureau
u.s census bureau right
and they provide the median home values
in every single city as well as the
median monthly rent the u.s
census bureau okay so here's a case
example if you're like dude you're a
little over my head here give me
something tangible boom i was just in
phoenix a couple weeks ago i saw the
numbers up by the way behind okay so we
can get into that we're gonna get in a
second
um
don't
don't go there yet yeah stay there i'll
tell you when to get there so let's use
a case example i was in phoenix i was
like all right what does it cost to
live in phoenix boom so the
median home value in phoenix is what
i've discovered is 230 000 median okay
the median annual rent is 12 000. so if
you you want to do this math the the
price to rent ratio
basically 230 000
divided by
12 000 are you doing that yeah what do
you got you got 19.
boom 19 okay 19 point something
something 19. all right but the answer
is 19. okay cool great what the hell
does that 19 mean to me let me tell you
here it is so if it's a price ratio of
i'm sorry 15 or less you should buy 15
or less
you should buy
if the price to rent ratio is 21 or more
you should rent where am i at 19.
exactly so you're 19 you're kind of in
the middle i don't know i don't know
you're literally smacked out of the
middle you're kind of closer to renting
meaning there's a there's a little gray
area you've got to figure it out
yourself so basically let's look at this
list right now and i said okay that's
phoenix how does that help me okay
now they're talking about that here are
the places where they're basically
saying you should 100
rent so just keep in mind these numbers
15 and 21 if it's below 15 buy it's if
it's above 21 rent now let's talk about
the most
opportune places to rent here are the
cities that you should be renting in
okay
san francisco oakland honolulu hawaii la
new york city they all have scores of
basically 40 or 50 36 for new york keep
scrolling down dave seattle 36 san jose
33 washington dc 33 keep going san diego
30 keep going keep going go faster
portland 29 boston 29 chula vista
california 25 denver 25 jersey 23 miami
23. stop right there austin 22. okay so
if you're living in those cities and if
you're going to use this formula just
rent
so it just almost validates everything
that i've been talking about
in living in miami like the math is
right there
basically saying we're 23. if you're
anything
over a 21 just rent okay great new york
city all my friends in new york city if
they spend a million dollars they'd
literally get a shoe box
like literally here's a shoe box live in
your freaking shoe box for a million
bucks
okay
go to the top san francisco and then we
can see these prices right here
600 grand to buy
for a thousand dollar rental in um san
francisco basically the numbers do not
support you buying anything in san
francisco just rent just rent in all
those okay so let's flip it let's flip
it go down to the very bottom of the
list these are the places that if you
live in you should
buy
these are the places you should buy and
they're not exactly the best cities
okay
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
these aren't exactly the cities you
wanna go vacation here we go you got
detroit five right if you're under 15
just buy basically detroit's saying
please
please move here please buy will make it
very much worth your while here are the
cities that you should buy in go fast
david yeah detroit cleveland memphis
toledo
buffalo pittsburgh milwaukee
baltimore lubbock texas el paso texas
indianapolis san antonio fort wayne
arlington texas fort worth texas philly
tulsa keep going until we hit 15.
st louis st pete all right so that's the
15. so basically what we're saying here
is this
the better the city like the more city
that you're likely to vacation and you
want to be at just rent
the cities that basically are like who
the hell would live in detroit
buy there
because the rent they make it basically
incentivize you right to buy right so
the the worse the city the more
likelihood you should buy they're going
to incentivize you to buy the better the
city the new york cities the san
francisco's the las the honolulu hawaii
the miami's just rent because the prices
are freaking out of control according to
this price to rent ratio this is math
can't argue with math
watch me buddy oh watch me
so
it's kind of like this it's kind of like
um
an analogy like
the worse you look
oh boy
maybe the nicer you should be
like
if you're not so good looking
yeah and you're yeah you're not fit and
you're not like
easy on the eyes
don't also be an dude i feel
that way about new york though
okay new york is the ugly you
think so like it's not so don't buy
there yeah uh but it's also like if
you're ugly be nice like detroit
so
might be nice on your prices uh new york
is stinky
it's dirty oh you do not talk about
new york buddy i love new york city i
love it
i love visiting when i was like this is
cool uh i'd hate to live here
but for a couple days vacation oh but
there there is something to be said like
look let's call a spade here if there's
a pretty girl you're talking to she's
hot she's sexy she's pretty she's got a
bad attitude
you're willing to be like i'll rent
yeah i'll deal with her for a little
while the shitty attitude but she looks
good you're willing to deal with more
okay for someone
who is like i see what you're trying to
see what i'm saying here 100 seriously
like if you're uh
unattractive city a cleveland like you
better make it worth my flight why the
hell would i live here if you're a fort
wayne yeah yeah
exactly
so i'm just i'm just kind of making an
analogy right no i agree i agree yeah i
see fabian say new york is awesome don't
about new york buddy cut your hands
off if you enjoyed that short clip from
the sauce cast click here to watch
another click here to watch the full
episode or just stay broken
you